how do you view going into the tie  breaker here in among us um no it's it's  okay uh i tried to press a little bit  i probably played inaccurately at some  point because i think i had some  advantage  then like i had some slight hope that  the pawn ending could be there could be  chances there but obviously there was  nothing  uh but overall  um  with the way things were standing draw  was a good result for me yeah because  the loss would have taken destiny out of  your hands right yeah now i know  regardless what happens now  i i will win the match if i win tomorrow  so that's that's good news uh but  obviously um  i  i will try my very best now to to gain  that extra point good luck thank you